the u.s. is considering whether to
expand the ban on laptops and other
large electronics on commercial flights
crossing the Atlantic now currently
passengers cannot carry devices larger
than a cell phone on nonstop flights to
the US from several airports in the
Middle East and North Africa sources
tell CBS News at airports in Europe
including the United Kingdom are among
those likely to be added to this list
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport right outside Washington Chris
good morning good morning we understand
the Department Homeland Security has
been regularly meeting with the airlines
who are expressing some concerns about
the prospect of widening this ban now
under the new rule any devices larger
than a cell phone would have to be
stored in the cargo hold there is
concern that could pose a fire risk due
to the lithium-ion batteries and so many
devices airlines are also worried an
expanded ban will hurt their bottom line
by discouraging business travelers who
work on long flights and after the
recent confrontations between airline
staff and customers like this
high-profile removal of a United
Airlines passenger airlines are hesitant
about the idea of potentially having to
individually search passengers for
electronic devices
US officials began discussing an
additional or wider electronic band
following the laptop bombing of a Somali
airliner last year the Obama
administration ultimately decided a
wider ban would be impractical but there
is concern an explosive that might not
be detected on airport scanners could
get on an aircraft and that's what's
driving this we understand DHS and the
airlines are set to meet again later
this week with a final decision coming
in the next few weeks
Charlie Chris thanks